[Musique]
la scène est extrêmement difficile à
tourner trois secouristes plonge dans
l'eau aux pâquis contaminé sous le
réacteur en feu c'est une course contre
la montre pour éviter une deuxième
explosion des millions de vies sont en
jeu
nous sommes sur le plateau de tournage
du film tchernobyl diab est la toute
première production cinématographique
russe qui explore les contrecoups du
désastre nucléaire de 1986
version patriotique mais dans le bon
sens du terme dit l'acteur et
réalisateur dany la cause l'obscur le
film se penche sur l'histoire de ces
trois héros méconnus qui ont en quelque
sorte sauvé une partie de l'europe en
1986 le producteur et le grand cinéaste
alexander zemlinsky de france
nous racontons pour la première fois
l'histoire de ces gens qui ont dû se
battre contre l'inefficacité du système
les mensonges et la technologie
tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui il dit
que la production a commencé bien avant
que la série age bio charme le grand
public l'été dernier mais concède que la
mini série américaine a ravivé l'intérêt
pour tchernobyl
avec ses cinq épisodes qui raconte
comment le régime soviétique à camoufler
la vérité
le tout avec un réalisme des armes les
français
trois décennies ont passé les mêmes la
splendeur des couleurs de l'automne
n'efface pas les ravages tchernobyl est
encore aujourd'hui le site le plus
contaminé de la planète mais il n'a
jamais été aussi populaire
nous y sommes allés au mois d'octobre et
les autobus de tous reste était encore
fait on pensait déjà à venir avant et
quand on a vu la saison c'est différent
il faut faut vraiment voir ça voir de
leurs propres yeux ces villages
abandonnés dans le rayon de 30
kilomètres qui entoure la centrale
accidentée
un périmètre condamné où il est en
principe interdit d'habiter babouche
part quelques exceptions près babouchka
maria comme tout le monde l'appelle ici
était femme de ménage à la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl et son mari
gardien de sécurité quand ils ont dû
évacuer en catastrophe en 1986 mais elle
est revenue
un an plus tard il n'est jamais reparti
soyez le 1er à droite performer
natologie fait australe son petit nid
douillet avec ses vignes ses fleurs ne
cache pas sa grande solitude ça revient
se régale donc de voir aujourd'hui les
gens débattent on chez elle à l'épreuve
et il y en a de plus en plus qui
s'aventurent dans ce musée à ciel ouvert
podomètre au cou et comptant rome car
certains secteurs sont plus radioactives
que d'autres à prochain
c'est un point 30 comme ce petit village
fanton explique notre guide victoria si
vous décidez d'habiter et c'est cela
peut être dangereux si vous continuez
par exemple des légumes des si mais si
on a visité la zone ça c'est pas
dangereux pour quelques minutes quelques
heures idem pour la désormais célèbre
ville de pripiat qui était la plus
proche de la centrale est un modèle à
l'époque soviétique avec ses manèges et
sa grande roue est devenu le sinistre
symbole de l'accident les autorités ont
mis deux jours avant d'évacuer ces
cinquante mille résidents j'avais
entendu parler de tchernobyl mais je
n'avais jamais saisi l'ampleur de la
catastrophe
ce visiteur anglais devant le réacteur
numéro 4 qui est aujourd'hui couvert
d'un immense donc de métal le
gouvernement de l'ukraine entend
d'ailleurs profiter de l'intérêt soudain
pour développer le tourisme davantage il
semble prêt à aller loin pour y arriver
il est désormais possible c'est tout
nouveau de visiter la célèbre salle de
contrôle du réacteur numéro 4 est juste
derrière nous faut une combinaison
spéciale et un masque à gaz
toutefois le taux de radiation
l'intérieur et 40 mille fois plus élevé
qu'il l'était c'est à l'extérieur la
plus part déjà refusé les on va passer
notre tour noces les biologistes et
timothée mousseau n'a rien contre le
tourisme mais pas aussi extrait il
visite régulièrement tchernobyl depuis
15 ans pour étudier la faune l'idée du
tourisme de masse dans des zones
sensibles comme pripyat inquiète
énormément
quant à moi la zone va rester quelque
chose unique et bien sûr comprendre que
c'est pas le disneyland de bien sûr que
c'est elle amusée et quand nous visitons
les eaux nous étendons que quelque chose
comme le tueur indicatif plutôt que le
tour de celle fille mais pour ceux qui
ont risqué leur vie en 1986 comme ses
deux pilotes d'hélicoptère l'attention
que reçoit tchernobyl était inespéré
après toutes ces années
ça nous rappelle que les efforts que
nous avons déployés n'était pas en vain
et que cela vaut encore la peine d'en
parler et d'exposer les faits après tant
de travail itt entre igor sont parmi
ceux qui ont dû survoler la centrale
durant les heures qui ont suivi
l'explosion pour il argué du sable
s'exposer à des doses de radioactivité
leur a coûté leur santé et leur carrière
août
john holmes il aura fallu une série
américaine pour réveiller la mémoire
collective
waouh ça nous a aidés aussi parfois on
est plus doué pour raconter les
histoires qui sont loin de notre réalité
tchernobyl était peut-être encore trop
proche de la nôtre
son film prendra l'affiché l'automne
prochain et contre toute attente c'est
rosatom l'agencé d'énergie atomique de
russie qui en finance une partie 30/3
leur a fallu pour surmonter la honte que
flaccide ans de tchernobyl pour l'ex
union soviétique est portée au grand
écran l'histoire de ces héros et de ses
survivre